we have a voicemail number it's 2192
david p let's hear from the egg man in
today's voicemail hey Dave I have a
contractor coming over my house today
give me an estimate of somewhere fancy a
call that springs up got out from storms
anyway the first thing I'm going to say
to this contractor is do not say
anything political to me do not try to a
good even attempt to discuss anything
political and then we'll say hopefully
okay then we'll get into my BRK do you
think that's a good way to approach any
kind of business deal because I feel
like if I don't say that the guy could
just drop one comment and I do actually
there's no way I'm giving this guy a
couple grand to fix my diagram terrified
of learning people's true motivations yo
yep I mean I I generally agree if it's
someone i'm only going to have a small
interaction with i'd rather just not
even know about their politics because
if i do know about their politics i'm
not going to want to do business with
them so i completely am on board with
Eggman here if their politics are
unsavory to me obviously yeah it just
comes across as they're not really being
professionals so I'm okay to entertain
their politics but I think it's really
on them they shouldn't be bringing it up
and also for you it's not about their
specific politics you just think it
shows a lack of professionalism if
random vendors who are providing a
service start talking about politics
like one of those things you don't
discuss with strangers and especially
for providing a service to you also the
Eggman's been calling in quite a bit
lately oh yeah the egg man's got a whole
racket going on there I mean it's
clearly he's very very wrapped up and
what's going on politically as we're
hearing we didn't hear from the guy for
like nine months I think at one point
and now he's back and floated the full
swing of things for sure I wonder what
he was doing yeah that's a real question
where was the Eggman for the nine months
that we didn't hear from him that's not
a question that we may soon and get an
answer to on the bonus show today google
street view cars are now going to be
spotting methane leaks in big cities
very interesting smartphones that can
accurately test your sperm count and i
will tell what has now been requested
many times the richard stallman in my
car story from when i gave Richard
Stallman a ride after the interview that
we did on the show don't miss today's
bonus show it's going to be a heck of a
bonus show david patten
slash membership the coupon code is
still active all one word all lower case
it is I voted 17 I will speak to you
then